dans ce laboratoire on transpire sur
demande
peu de gens le savent mais c'est la
canicule à longueur d'année au centre
hippique de l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal
essentiellement on peut y pratiquer
comme un gros frigo mais qui fait du
chaud et du froid depuis 2010 est cette
chambre environnementale re créer toutes
sortes de conditions climatiques
on aura un gros projet en ce moment où
on simule des canicules des canicules
typique de nord-américaine donc un peu
comme ici dans les trentaine de degrés
avec beaucoup d'humilité mais également
des canicules plus typique de
l'australie donc beaucoup plus chaud
dans la quarantaine de degrés mais plus
c'est bon ça va nous permettre de
mesurer et à tempe et assurent en temps
réel et voir si tout va bien
l'australienne georgia chase sling fait
partie de l'équipe de chercheurs
montréalais
elle prépare les participants qui vont
passer jusqu'à trois heures ou chaud
on mesure la sudation de façon très
précise et tous les signes vitaux sont
suivis à la trace dans cette surtout à
des personnes qui sont entre 50 et 80
ans et qui ont une maladie cardiaque
connue le but voir comment on peut
limiter les effets néfastes des
canicules en mesurant les biens faits
réels de certaines interventions tout
simple d'utilisation du ventilateur dont
le chantier attend que tout le monde
vraiment chez soi est ce que ça
fonctionne est ce que c'est bon ou non
on évalue également limite ification de
la peau donc de s'éponger la peau avec
de l'eau l'utilité joens l'attend ça
dépend de la capacité de la personne à
produire de la soie puis lorsqu'on
vieillit on est moins capable de
produire de la soie
quand on transpire on trouve ça
désagréable c'est colin c'est pas très
confortable mais c'est notre méthode de
refroidissement le plus puissant donc
c'est très important d'être capable de
transpirer ce qui est important c'est
surtout l'évaporation de cette
transpiration lot
les résultats ne seront connus que dans
deux ans environ
mais en ces temps de changement
climatique et de vieillissement de la
population il pourrait mener à des
applications très concrètes
ici à louise despatie radio canada
montréal